hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well okay so we have
this this distinction that she's making
that you know but she's not the first
person to come up with this a lot of
people throughout history are
distinguishing between the household or
the private life and the more public you
know area which is which is seen as more
important which is seen as more truly
human this is where natural things take
place the animal things take place this
is where distinctively human rational
things take place like you know in
politics you have deliberation right
people are supposed to ideally be
figuring out what the common good is not
just their own goods or the marketplace
people are you know engaging in rational
choice behavior trying to maximize
profits or things like that education is
supposed to be primarily intellectual
yeah this gets tied in with with mail
and then this gets seen he has the
province of the female so you know in a
certain way the private gets turned into
all the extra stuff that helps me happen
in order for this to exist but isn't
really that important
that distinctively human and we didn't
we were doing moral theory we don't have
to think about that much of our value
with that much we look at this stuff and
stuff so how does this play itself out
she says well you know first of all
these are not so neatly separated two
things in this realm excuse me over here
impact things over here she has some
examples are politics she says you know
the personal is highly affected by the
political power beyond legislation about
abortion is one example a lot of
feminists are interested in that but
here's probably a even broader issue
grading earning power of men yet in most
generations as it turns out actually the
there's some of mixed evidence about
your generation of my generation but in
general women been learning much less
than men for the same kind of work yeah
that's something that takes place in the
marketplace but it really affects
people's homes doesn't it affects their
personal life it restricts their
abilities engaged in the sort of things
that they want to it limits
potentialities the interconnected
division of labor by gender both within
and beyond the households you can think
of traditional gender roles you know
again your generation my generation
those things are a bit more evened out
but not completely evened out I can tell
you that that your great grandparents
generation and my grandparents
generation the men did a lot less
housework if any than
the women did you know I remember going
to my uncle's house wants to stay with
him for a week and when I'd like to use
the stove because I cook turned out you
didn't even have it like hooked up to
the gas line and I said what's wrong
with this they said I never use it
and I open up the refrigerator it was
all TV dinners they got a microwave he
never learned how to cook
you know why he never learned how to
cook because he never had to cook
because he was never expected to cook
because his mom or you know whoever you
know whatever woman was around was
taking care of that so you know these
things affect each other quite a bit the
marketplace affects the household the
political system affects the household
education even affects the household she
goes on and she talks about what goes on
in the house and the things that she's
focused on most she doesn't talk much
about likes in cooking or cleaning or
watching TV or what else to be doing
households cuddling up with the dogs or
playing games yeah what does she focus
on the most mothering when she talks
about two main things she talks about
childbearing itself and then she talks
about child raising and I want to read
you something that she's saying here
about that she says was on page 335
dominant patterns of thought I've seen
women as primarily mothers and mothering
as the performance of a primarily
biological function which means that if
you're a mother you're just doing
something that's instinctual it's so
it's not something that you have to make
a choice about that is fulfilling you as
a human being you know as a rash
human being is something that is just
you know part of your your organic
nature so it's been supposed that while
engaging in political life the things
over here or you know going off to work
or something like that is it
specifically human activity women are
engaged in activity which is not
specifically human why not well because
you know don't cats have kittens and
dogs puppies and mice have little mice
whatever they're called from I mean even
birds you know I have little little
chicks very technical Thanks yeah and
then reptiles you know at least still
they lay the eggs and they can sit up
for a while sometimes they'll eat their
young but you know go further down
there's less and less care about it
isn't there but mammals in general take
care of their young don't think so it's
more of a just animal activity and not
really a distinctively human that's the
view that she wants to attack here she's
saying that's a misguided way of looking
at things
so she says human a human mother is an
extremely different activity from a
mothering engaged in by other animals
what do you think does that does that
make sense
why would that be the case I mean how
many of you had pets like a dog or a cat
that he had babies it's probably food if
you did it was probably a cat right
because they you know they forget to
spay him and then they come back yeah I
mean what do they do they nurse them all
right well so they do with babies
keep them warm they take care of them so
they providing food warmth yeah
yeah or other cats to Tomcats and try to
kill though the kittens
and they'll fight with the Tomcat -
scared away so shelter protection food
warmth anything else are providing it
with do they love their kids do you
think they do I've seen cats like walk
away yeah I actually lived in a trailer
park for a while when I was a grad
student and there were lots of stray
cats now there was a mom cat whose
kittens like nurse way too long because
they would actually there were five of
them and they would knock her down and
like one would hold her down while the
other ones would nurse and of course she
start getting weaker and weaker and
weaker because you're you're losing
sustenance and of course they get got
gets stronger and stronger and stronger
till one day she ran away because she
was trying to save her her cat life now
I don't think the babies were like yeah
let's kill them aha they were following
biological instincts right what are what
are some of the things that mom can't do
that are you know we might think are
loving towards their kids yeah yeah they
clean them all the time of that you know
cats clean each other when they get
older you know when it can't likes you
and it does the milk dance thing that's
that's a imitating it's off being a kid
you're like it's mom yeah then they they
start getting their claws into so
there's a lot of biological things and
it is their affection there I think you
know you could say there's something
like affection now is that like human
affection for a child what do you think
and put aside moms who don't actually
seem to like their kids you know there's
plenty of them up there
she's not talking about that so do that
with your kids when they turn 18 you
know yeah cuz you'll call them up see
how they're doing
yeah you're right
there's a light blowing bond that takes
place again the relationship is good
some some kids are like as soon as I'm
18 I'm out of here I'm never gonna see
ya I was lying to myself so I can
understand them she says in here the
work and speech of men is recognized
very different from what might be
thought it was the work and speech of
other animals human mothering is fully
was different from other from animal
mother
how so she says human mothering does
some very important things it shapes
language and culture it forms human
social personhood and it develops
morality that's worth sort of dwelling
on if there's anything to underline in
that section that's probably human
mothering shapes language and culture
where did you actually learn language
from you learn it first in the home
where do you first acquire what we call
culture in the home you're an orphan
okay at the orphanage but generally it's
in some sort of home environment there's
a reason why we call you know something
a mother tongue or you know entraps
literally the
the mother language it's because most
people learn it from interacting with
their father and probably also their
father right that's an important thing
the cats actually have to learn how to
be out from from their mom that's
hardwired there are some things that
they have to learn how to kill mice
believe it or not cats that don't learn
how to how to hunt and kill properly
they will play with a mouse for a long
time if they have no idea how to break
its neck and kill them but they can also
clone their from a male cat
I had a kitten that learned from a male
cat how to hunt them and kill them
that's rescue so there are some things
that they learn but think about just how
much a human baby has to learn and how
much of that is dependent on somebody
caring about it and being patient with
it because you know human babies are
totally almost everything from the start
and even when they start developing
motor skills you know parents that gets
really miraculous oh my god is taking
the first steps but you know those are
those are not great steps it's not like
a deer with you know within a day the
little fawn can run about with us it
takes like a year before the kid can't
even like get itself up and start to get
out on two feet and it takes a long time
before the kid is anything but wobbly so
somebody actually has to care about that
kid and encourage it and you know keep
trying right that's what human mothering
or nurturing and it does form social
human social personhood going back to
that conception of attachment there is
there's a basic level of attachment that
he has to take place in order for
being to be able to relate to anybody
generally that takes place between the
child of the parent it can happen with
other people but if attachment disorder
you know psychologists call it takes
place that kid is gonna have very bad
outcomes which other because it's such a
massive Mehta complex that affects
everything else so socialization takes
place in the household it doesn't take
place for primarily in the marketplace
or in the schools or you know out
politics
babies aren't participating in politics
are they kids aren't what else develops
morality the home is the first school
for moral life isn't it
when kids you know turn out screwed up
there is something to looking at the
parents I'm gonna have to say that the
parents are integrally to play but there
is something that's supposed to happen
within the whole isn't there do you have
somebody who is a sadist are they going
to raise a kid who is well-adjusted
probably not because they're not
supplying something that that kid
absolutely needs and worth of
development so she goes on she says
human mothering can be as fully a
creative activity as those activities
traditionally thought of as
distinctively human what are some of
those you know again economic activity
intellectual activity artistic
production why because what is it you
what is what is human nurturing you it
creates new persons and new types of
persons that's just as creative as
making new objects or products or
institutions it's kind of an interesting
thing to think of that
so she says there's no reason to think
of for example human nurse anymore
simply biological than there is to think
of say a businessman going out with
colleagues that way it's all cultural
it's culturally imbued it has a natural
basis but it's you know something that
is imbued with culture and passes on
culture so she says they actually moral
theory should concern itself first of
all with the activity of creating new
persons and look at that very carefully
and you know issue right in saying that
maybe Kant and Bentham maybe even
Aristotle haven't looked at this as
carefully as they should have I think
she is right she says we have to look at
what its norms and practices ought to be
and with how the institutions and
arrangement throughout society and the
world ought to be structured to
facilitate the right kind of development
of the best kinds of new persons and
here's another sort of lapidary sentence
of hers
the flourishing of children ought to be
in the very center of moral and social
and political and economic and legal
thought so that's that's a pretty
revolutionary thing to say isn't the
flourishing of children rather than you
know say the gross national product or
you know the greatest happiness
principle or doing duty for its own sake
the flourishing of children want to be
the main thing that we look at
that would be quite a change with so
that would require a very different
understanding of the relationship
between the private or the personal and
the public the private or the personal
would then become much more important
and again who are we learning this
lesson from whether there are a lot of
male theorists you know advancing these
claims you know in historical terms no
it's been mainly women doing that's why
this is identified with with feminist
scholarship